hi there here we are number four and
Stephen Covey's Habits of Highly
successful people win win all right now
in negotiations win-win means that I'm
not gonna try to impose something on you
that's only gonna benefit me and not
benefit you if I can come up with
something that benefits you and benefits
me we both win that's far more likely to
be a successful negotiation successful
business relationship or even a
successful discussion with someone is
working for you how does it apply the
language training or language learning I
think I meet so many people who are
constantly negative about themselves
when it comes to language learning they
say I can't do this I can't do that I've
been trying to understand I don't
understand I keep forgetting my words I
wanna go to speak I'm tongue-tied
I mean there's no end of complaints that
people have about their own performance
in the language the fact is that
language learning takes time you are
moving from the comfort of your own
language where you understand everything
and you can express yourself as an adult
and now you're trying to start all over
again in another language it takes time
and everything is very foggy and
uncertain for a long time and my own
experience is if I look something up in
the dictionary
I forget the meaning as soon as I close
the dictionary that's why I don't use
traditional dictionaries it's just a
waste of time
that's why we have our our system but
there's a lot of frustrating things in
language learning you have to realize
that going in so once you accept that
then all of the time that you spend with
the language speaking it listening to it
reading it with however much difficulty
and however it didn't maybe meet your
expectations it's a win because you need
to spend that time with the language so
if you have struggled through a text and
you still don't understand it or you can
read it but then when you go to listen
to it you don't understand it all of
these things which can be frustrating
shouldn't be frustrating you say to
yourself great I did that I was
you know had enough willpower staying
power to spend that half hour that hour
and I'm gonna do the same thing again
tomorrow and every time I do that I'm
gaining slowly on the language and I've
experienced this so many times when it
seems that for months and months I just
can't seem to understand it I can get
now to where I can read it I can get to
where actually I can actually hear the
words I know where they sort of end and
the next word begins but I still can't
understand it and yet eventually I do so
whatever time you spend with the
language is a win it's a win-win
situation thanks for listening bye for
now